[Music]
in this video we shall do a comparison
of the 1993 super mecha godzilla versus
the 2021
most verse mecha godzilla well the name
mechagodzilla comes from the word mecca
which is derived from mechanical and
godzilla it has always been a rival and
an arch enemy of godzilla
ever since its first appearance in the
1970s however in this video we shall
look
past the other makers and concentrate on
two of the biggest and most powerful
versions
the 1993 super and the godzilla vs score
mecca
so let's see who you support tell us in
the comments section
and also subscribe if you haven't so now
let's get down with this sickness
size super mecha godzilla was the
largest version of the character in the
past
it was bigger than godzilla and also
weighed more than him it stood 120
meters tall
on 393 feet which was 20 meters taller
than the 100 meter godzilla
it also weighed 150 482 tons
in its super form most of us
mechagodzilla however was even
bigger or at least taller than the
supermaker godzilla of 1993.
this iteration of the mecca was by far
the biggest towering over 120 meter tall
godzilla which would easily
put him around 140 or 450 to 460 feet
tall
and as for weight it would have been
close to or maybe even surpassed the
2021 godzilla's figure of 164
000 tons now let's see its origins
first appearing in the 1993 godzilla vs
mechagodzilla 2
this version became an icon later on
well
in the movie the united nations godzilla
countermeasure center
used futurian technology scavenged from
the remains of mecca king ghidorah
to build mechagodzilla which was
operated by its military branch the
geforce
and g4 started building a much more
powerful much more sophisticated robot
in godzilla's image using future and
technology
salvaged from the mecca king ghidorah's
central head
in the monster verse however due to the
2014 attack of the murals and the
awakening of the tyrants in
king of the monsters the fact that
mankind was relatively powerless in the
face of these titans didn't go unnoticed
despite the fact that godzilla has
proven to be a savior a corporation set
out to dethrone him and restore humanity
as the world's
dominant power apex cybernetics started
developing a weapon capable of defeating
the titans
by using the remains of king ghidorah
now as for the design the body of jesus
mecha godzilla is made of a gleaming
silver alloy
and its eyes are orange in color on his
chest belly
arms and legs it has a well-defined
musculature
on the front of its neck are a series of
vents and its head is crowned with a
curved spike
its dorsal plates are slightly shorter
and square shaped than godzilla's but
there are still
three rows of them the tale of
mechagodzilla is also shorter than that
of godzilla and it does not hit the
ground
but for the inclusion of garuda attached
to its back it retains the same
appearance as supermaker godzilla
the monster verse mecha godzilla has a
series of short metal plates that extend
from the back of its neck to the tip of
its tail
similar to godzilla's dorsal blades it
has four psychodactyl claws on its hands
and its four limbs are much bulkier
and slightly longer than that of the
true godzillas the feet also seem to be
a little more like ghidorah's but
also has a godzilla's frame in it
mechagodzilla's tail also has a drill
mountain on its tip
overall the mecha looks to be more of a
walking skeleton with no emphasis on
external alloy skins
to make it look smooth like the earlier
makkers
powers and weapons supermaker godzilla
has a wide range of attacks and weapons
in its arsenal
first was its mega buster beam that can
be shut from its mouth and was equal in
power to the atomic breath
mechagodzilla can also fire yellow
colored laser cannons from its eyes
although it was not viewed as a close
combat weapon system
it did have two shock anchors which were
upgraded to the g
crushes over time that destroyed
godzilla's secondary brain and paralyzed
him
it also had paralyzer and tranquilizer
missiles
which were used to slow down and stun
the g-man its most powerful weapon
however was the plasma grenade
which used to absorb atomic breath of
godzilla and fired
back at him with an amplified extra
force
it was armored with a diamond coated
alloy and can hover attack
using the high power maser beam cannon
from the garuda weapon system
most of us make a godzilla on the other
hand is a close combat fighter and is
equipped with a crane-like claws
allowing them to cut through flesh while
grabbing it can even rotate its hands
like drills
delivering extra damage with plasma
charged blows
it was made from an unclassified alloy
that was very durable
it has shoulder-mounted missile
launchers capable of momentarily
stunning the g-man
it has thrusters mounted on its back and
sides
enabling quick bursts of movement or
added momentum to its strikes
and its tail is equipped with a deadly
drill that can be folded into a blade
its ultimate weapon however was the red
proton scream
which was a red energy beam that can
overpower the atomic breath
however it is its fast reflexes that was
the deciding factor in the battle
against godzilla
and so with that we come to the end of
this video do tell us your thoughts in
the comments section below
tell us which one do you prefer in a
one-on-one battle
anyway that's the comparison between the
1993 supermaker godzilla and the 2021
most of us mechagodzilla do hit that
like button for support
and subscribe to be a part of the
minecube family as well as smash that
bell button for regular updates on
master videos
right here on minecube take care fam